united airline hits back
at pilot training diversity and here's
what they have to say
this is a simple flying article okay
last week united airlines shared that it
has helped pledge 1.2 million
on scholarship fees to ensure its pilot
training school is more diverse overall
the united
aviate academy will train 5 000 new
pilots by 2030
with the goal of to have at least 50
percent of the new students be
women or people of color however
this announcement was met with a mixed
reaction to which the chicago-based
carrier has now responded some people
voiced that the race and gender
shouldn't be a factor in hiring policy
they expressed that qualification should
be the key factor united share the
following on twitter to clarify the
hiring policy all the highly qualified
candidates we accept
into the academy regardless of race or
sex will have met or exceeded the
standards
we set for admittance tom i'm gonna go
to you first with this one because i got
strong opinions on this one
i got a very strong opinion on this
because there are upstream problems or
downstream problems and
conservatives like me tend to go
upstream and
unfortunately a lot of my liberal
friends tend to do downstream here's an
upstream and downstream problem so i'll
do metaphor quick
there's a polluted stream okay so we're
standing at the end of a polluted stream
and the liberal friend says we need a
multi-trillion dollar
filter to clean the stream and you're
going to pay for it over here
whereas the conservative goes wait a
minute why don't we go upstream and find
out
what's putting the pollution in there
and you find a campsite you find other
things
putting crap in the water so you say
let's stop that
and i think this is an upstream
downstream problem the downstream isn't
like
in the hiring office that you should be
hiring you know people that are not as
qualified just so you can meet some sort
of quota
on diversity i want to say how do we go
upstream
and enable more people of color and
diverse
backgrounds to get into flight school
when they're 20 years old how do we make
it
attractive um you know career so people
thinking about it can get into flight
school so at the end of the day
people with five years of flight school
experience and they got their license
and multi-engine they've gone through
this whole thing
and now we have a natural diversity
because there's a bunch of qualified
people from all kinds of backgrounds
because we go upstream and we attract
them i'm not big on downstream problems
like this it says at the end of the day
you have to make certain compromises and
i don't think air safety is a place to
do it
should we have more people of color and
women in the cockpit
yes but let's go upstream and make it
attractive for them to go get educated
and they'll compete for the job like
everybody else and they'll be great
qualified
pilots of all kinds of backgrounds that
the average person can feel perfectly
great about whoever is flying their
planet interesting interesting analogy
what do you think the whole time he's
talking about upstream downstream i'm
just thinking of tom sawyer tom with his
uh just
doing his thing yeah that was what was
on my mind
don't mess with me i'm on a roll oh
you're on a roll so here's where i'm
going with this because i did an episode
a couple months ago called the nasdaq's
gone woke
and um ariana friedman i believe is her
name is the president of the nasdaq and
she's basically implementing
all these rules within the nasdaq about
diversity
and inclusion and how many board members
have to be female
or you know of a certain color and
for the most part she was implementing
this throughout the nasdaq and it was
sort of
met with for the most part good reviews
okay and
whether you know so basically here's my
point i'm all for
inclusion and diversity and when the
nasdaq
nasdaq went woke i was you know kind of
with that here's the flip side of that
i'm all for that until you know i'm
flying on a plane the only freaking
thing i care about is getting to where
i'm going safely
this is the one time where i'm just like
yo i don't give a [ __ ]
if there's 10 000 white guys and they're
all pilots i could care less about
diversity
if they all just get me to where i'm
going safely this is the one time where
this is this this whole attack on
you know white people for the most part
i just can't play that game with
um with flying just because flying
i mean look how many plane crashes have
happened over the last five years
like i don't remember a time other than
9 11 when planes were just going down
boeing how many have you ever done a
case study on boeing what's happening
with them
i i actually did a uh a beer in business
uh conversation with phil kondit the
ex-ceo of boeing of course
and he talked about the 737 maxinet so
to me scaring flying what i'm saying is
that was an aircraft issue
okay that was a bad design in there that
that uh there's issues that's going on i
mean
software in certain conditions yeah
so but safe flying especially these days
is such a concern and i there's you see
grown men in planes that just like
scared to fly the number one thing is
making sure the pilots and the planes
are safe
this is not the place to start playing
the whole game bbd
so okay so let's talk about this first
of all uh the statement is made saying
what that the fact
uh 50 are going to be new students are
going to be women
or people of color right okay do you
know what percentage of americans are
black african americans probably 13
percent 13 points 13
13 to 16. 13.4 which means
united airlines is essentially becoming
racist against whites to not rate no not
higher whites if you're going to go this
is a mathematical conversation you're
like
go down i'm going to go deeper for you
know those females this is let me know
this is a mathematical conversation
they're having here it's pure math for
me okay
here's the other thing for you uh what
percent of ob gyn
is men and women 10 years ago what
percentage of ob gyn
is men or women 10 years ago the last
time i went to an ob gyn what do you
think i mean i'm just asking
what do you think i would say 80 men you
think 80 men what do you think i thought
i would think you say 10 years ago 10
years ago i would say 10 years it was
probably 90
men still okay it was 57 percent men
today it's 55
of women okay okay but it used to be men
before now it's women
okay a little bit it is what it is okay
nurses what percentage of nurses
according to
u.s bureau of labor statistics are men
today
what percentage of nurses are men
today male what percentage like a male 1
30 30 percent
nurse like a gaylord [ __ ] yeah what
percentage are nurses
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with 30. 30.
what do you think
according by to pull it up what
percentage are men what do you think it
is
i would say 10 20 years ago i would say
80 20
female to male i would say it's closer
to 60 40 now watch the number here pull
it up according to a lit
12 percent are meant to be they're not
even none of those only 12
are men today nurses are we going out
there saying this is racist
this is sexist why are only 12 percent
men and by the way 40 years ago 50 years
ago was only 2.7
i think it says 1970 was 2.7 percent
right
so so so the point is this is not about
you ever force somebody to do something
what happens to them when you force
someone to do something do they like it
do people like force
they don't like it united airlines
trying to force people to want to be
pilots dude i don't want to be a pilot
what if i'm a woman and i don't want to
be a pilot it's force
it's mathematically not the right
direction to go and quite frankly to me
united airlines is being racist against
people
this is not you cannot win in this
argument there is no winning in this
argument
there's no way you can win in an
argument like this you sit there and say
hey
you know i noticed your friends uh the
percentage of your friends not enough of
them are
are uh white and not enough of them are
asian and not
when i grew up a hundred percent of my
friends were armenian what does that
make me racist
when i went into the army and i was at
the hundred first airborne division air
assault
guess what eighty percent of them were
white and nineteen percent were black
and then it was you know you put a
little latino in there but you pretty
much so majority were white
then it's blacks then it's latinos then
it's asians and the rest
so what if the military is racist so it
it
you cannot have the same thing be the
case in every single
industry it's a couple things you look
at here now let's flip it let's flip and
let's just say i did a video the other
day for the armenian community
and the armenian community video that i
did i call that parents
i call that armenian parents is what i
did flat out i said armenian parents i'm
talking to and i spoke in armenia
and i rarely do this i don't do armenian
videos so they say can you please speak
in armenia because people wonder if you
speak armenian or not i said i speak a
little bit armenian but it's
street armenian i don't speak like
armenia proper armenian so i spoke to
our minister can we get a sample i'd
love to hear it i said i'd like to
i'd like to speak to the parents and
then i said
you know mama papa says
i want to talk to you guys about what
you're doing with your kids today
raising them right got it
i said stop telling your kids that
unless they become doctors lawyers
dentist attorneys they're not successful
stop saying that to your kids stop
saying that they have to be a doctor
lawyer dentist okay you know what it
does
it creates the pressure for the kid to
be a what something he doesn't want to
be i had a guy a
girl at ucla medical center she was what
do you call the doctors that's for eye
what's the uh optical
ostomologist so she sits there persian
girl beautiful girl
i saw how long you've been doing this
for 15 years how do you like your job
can i close the door so yeah sure she
closed the door i hate my job
what then why you've been doing it for
15 years because i make too much money
that i can't leave
why'd you become an ophthalmologist to
make
my parents happy to make my parents
happy
i am miserable she went on a 10-minute
rant i was doing an executive health
stuff that this guy recommended me to do
at ucla tom she went on a 10-minute rant
about how much she hates my job and then
she says
let me check your eyes how your eyes are
after she said
it is what it is it depends on the day
so the point is to force people to do
something they don't want to do
flip it let me go now the other side of
the argument okay so
take any nationality any nationality
like when i talk to the jewish community
i'm like why do jewish
folks typically you know they get judged
for doing well financially oh because
you guys are cheap
what does that really mean when you say
jews are cheap what do you mean by
jewish people are cheap
why are you guys cheap why this is it in
your blood
is your blood dna like a type of c
and it's what the cheap is that what the
is the blood type is or is it because
when you were raised in a church in a
you know whatever you went synagogue
your family the thing is
save your money do this be frugal maybe
the values that were taught that you
were growing up had to do with that
right
okay maybe the middle eastern community
has to encourage more entrepreneurship
maybe the black african-american
community they need to teach
folks to want to go into business more i
don't know maybe become
like i was in chicago one time doing an
event at ritz carlton
and i walked in no joke i walked in 2
000
sharp black african american kids
18 19 20 year old kids okay looking like
a million bucks
guys and girls i said what's going on
over here
we are part of this uh lawyer whatever
future lawyers uh black lawyers of
america
i see you got to be kidding me no where
did the inspiration come for this
barack obama fantastic i love that
because that is like you're encouraging
to go out there and want to become
lawyers are people waking up saying
hey son i want you to grow up and be a
pilot no one says go be a pilot a kid
becomes a pilot because
almost every person that's a pilot
they're a pilot because their parent was
a pilot or because
they're like i love playing with these
planes and what if one day
you don't force somebody to become a
pilot they choose to become a pilot so
this is a
publicity stunt that makes them look
like fools is what it does
for united airlines to make a comment
like that that here's what we're going
to do moving forward
go study math and study data it doesn't
work in your favor
and it's quite offensive when you say
here's what we're going to move and how
about the rest of us
how about the wrestlers when you say
something like that no i don't i don't
like their marketing
approach they took and quite frankly
it's just to try to get some people to
say
oh they are very diverse today and
they're willing to work with everybody
they don't work too well for me but
there's something that really had me
revved up uh recently
is um bailey's thinking about colleges
looking around and
doing her research and she's looking at
yale she's looking at pen
she's looking at vanderbilt and things
like this she's got the grades
and i'm like you study what you want to
study so we can do a whole
discussion about that i'm not directing
her one way or the other i'm just saying
whatever you study in college
make it useful i'm not going to pay for
you to go to france and study
you know the history of art you know i
don't know what you would do with that
if you really want to do that we can
talk
but we we stumbled onto this pbd very
very interesting
yale was suddenly you know she's
studying uh she googles yale at missions
there's this massive lawsuit where
caucasians and asians were saying
that yale was so horribly
overcompensating
that they were actually discriminating
against caucasians
of asians having anything close to a
fair shot to get into the school
and so they took him to court yale
on the you can't prove that we did it
you can't
prove that we really conspired among the
admissions committee there's no emails
there's not that
you can't prove we conspired and said
what are you talking about
look at look at these people that got in
look at the diversity of that
look who didn't get in and let's go look
at test scores and let's look at you
know capabilities and achievement
now there's a place for scholarship and
there's a place to get people step
up what they don't want to talk about is
that a lot of these kids that were that
got in
so that yale could say we are so diverse
we are wondering so
yale gets the marketing right yale gets
social pressure off their back because
hey we're being diverse
and guess what happens a higher percent
of those kids are flunking out
at the end of sophomore year with big
student loans because
yale's not cheap and they were not their
100 scholarships
get it so now yale gets the merit badge
but you actually do somebody a non-favor
at times when you open doors like
pressure it's pressure to
act like you are all-inclusive and it
backfires on you because you pissed
somebody off look
uh in our comments i'm saying it
backfires on some of these people that
we're at
of course there's poor people now a
giant student look at our company
look at our company like insurance
company php okay we're 50
latino okay we just
are it's like okay we're 50 latino then
we're 25
african-american our caucasian is 13
what am i gonna do do we make that up
that sound on the background i hear
something that's coming up i don't know
what that is
okay can you guys hear it or not it went
away for a second
but do you still hear it or no i do
is this still there okay so so you look
at how did this happen did i say
here's what the percentage needs to be
this is what this needs to be
or did we just become like that because
it come and i'm from iran
so i'm middle eastern i'm christian i'm
armenian i'm a syrian how did i attract
latinos how did i attract it's just the
culture of the company that this took
now by the way the industry
is what percentage i would say maybe
even the average agent is a 59 year old
white male
you go to the traditional insurance
industry everyone's white you know we're
okay it's a multicultural that's what
happened to us
because that's what we talked about we
would like to be a multicultural company
somebody in here said two people said f
obama and another person said yeah
you know f obama uh
i don't i don't subscribe to that
mindset by the way politically
philosophically we are on complete
opposite ends when by the way and i will
say right now today
as crazy as this sounds barack obama
today is more like john f kennedy than
it was 15 years ago barack obama's not
the barack obama of 2005.
barack obama's not the barack obama of
2010. barack obama today ever since he
started getting paid and he's going to
have a life to live for another 40 years
he's starting to realize we can't just
tax everybody
today's barack obama is a different
barack obama 10 years ago but go back
and say f obama
um i applaud competitors
who think long term and for republicans
who get upset and they say f obama
no f your strategies is what i say your
strategies
suck why don't you get together and put
some good strategies together because
democrats are out strategizing you
and it pisses you off go get pissed off
about the strategies you're getting
putting together rather than getting
pissed off at somebody else under
opposing get
that's doing a better job than you you
got to salute your competitors
it's simple as that rather than getting
upset at the competitor you got to say
what
salute i respect you i've lost
throughout my
career god knows how many times i've
lost and i've sat there and said
damn more power to them good for them
let's sit down and look and see what
we're doing here wrong that they're
doing right maybe we can learn from it
that's the one part that sometimes
politically people become blinded oh
f trump oh f obama oh nope
strategy strategy strategy take a step
back and look what's going on and quite
frankly i just don't like
united airlines strategy we had somebody
that just commented i want to read her
comment
uh she just gave five bucks and she said
um julia
swenson she says you can't pick and
choose everything should be based on
qualifications i don't want to be hired
anywhere because i'm a girl it's
ridiculous that's what julie just said
right
then kevin gave five bucks and he says
question number one should there be any
diversity requirement
in companies and number two shouldn't we
focus on skill experience and character
when hiring
okay let's answer each question should
there be any diversity requirement for
companies what do you think tom
yeah i think companies should uh have to
prove that they have a
non-discriminatory open door to receive
anyone of any background so that the
selection process
can be completed i think there has to be
there has to be
i i must i think there must be look are
you letting
anyone you know you know show up at the
front door in my fact google did
something very interesting you know what
they did
they took names and cities off resumes
and they had hiring managers looking at
the resumes and guess what they found
out
they found out that they had a more
neutral selection process
that there was i love that there were
little things in the back of people's
minds that were thinking about
oh this person comes from daly city i
wonder if they went to a good college i
wonder where they come from
whereas this one came from oh it was in
uh you know atherton then went to
stanford it must be a really smart
person
so they took a lot of this stuff off and
also they did a little um
uh you know ethnic analysis you know
lashika jones
hmm you know it it has a cultural
connection to it that you might assume
when they took all that out they got
more neutralness i think companies
should be held to
are you allowing every person regarding
a background
their resume to get in and be part of
the filtering process
are you allowing that to happen and so
then from there
are you just do you show that you have a
fair and reasonable this is our criteria
we need a pilot pilot has to have this
many hours in the sky
has to have this and then we evaluate
how many of these people have that
we'll take the best one and if it
happens to be a white guy it's a white
guy happens
what is his hispanic woman's hispanic
woman just to build on what you're
saying
qualification should be the first and
foremost factor when highlighting i feel
like
then there's then there's other factors
yeah race
sex all that kind of stuff like that so
i'll give you a couple different
examples
raise adam by five percent go ahead keep
going five percent i'll just speaking of
the mic
well in the nfl they have something
called the rooney rule you're familiar
with the rooney rule that um basically
every nfl team when they're looking for
a candidate has to hire i'm sorry
consider hiring a black candidate it's
the rooney rule
so when you have mike tomlin that got
his job who basically was the youngest
coach to ever win a super bowl
for the pittsburgh steelers he
potentially a decade or so ago
before he got the job wouldn't have been
in the running so to speak
but now because of the rooney rule he
was a they had to interview a black
candidate he turned out to be a great
candidate
point is that's just the rooney rule in
the nfl where i don't know
kai if you want to pull it up rooney
rule an nfl team has to
consider within their candidates a black
candidate
a couple different things when it comes
to qualifications now there's here's
some qualifications you get percentages
of people who are nurses you get
percentage of people
um who different jobs what percentage of
male or female are construction workers
it's it's night and day exactly sure so
99
of a guy just commented saying why don't
we have all the women go become rec
players and see what happens
noel zenterman said let's make 50 a
female bricklayer quota play their game
and see how long they'll be there we go
what percentage of people are okay so
now obviously you know i go out in south
beach what percentage of
bottle servers waitresses are men
no they're 100 female because when
you're buying bottles and you're
spending thousands of dollars at the
club you want some hot chicks coming
over with sparklers that's just
part of the game so can a guy bring a
bottle over to your table
just as well as a female yeah sure but i
don't want six dudes rolling up at my
table
when i'm buying bottles bring some
chicks over there that's just the game
that we're playing
yeah so qualifications are great but
then age sex
color that is a factor i'm sorry yeah so
so let me give you some data
hockey what percentage of hockey players
are black one percent two percent it's
five percent
43 that's actually good for them five
percent of hockey players are black
43 percent 43 hockey players are black
today three of them are for detroit red
wings it's a record first time ever
where one team has three of them
they got three of them on there nfl nfl
70 are black okay so so
that's nba the nba is probably even a
bigger number what percentage of uh what
percentage
of i'm guessing nba players are
nba 74.2 percent okay nba okay so does
that make nba racist
no they're just a lot of people are
better
does that make nhl racist no does that
make nfl racist
nhl is 95 black 95 white is it
racist nba is seventy four point two
percent black are they racist
nfl is seventy percent black are they
racist against others
no here's what it is kids are growing up
if you really wanna see a change in this
if a black kid is playing with
dad what what game is dad playing is
that playing hockey is that playing
baseball that playing basketball what's
that playing
right whatever that game is i tell you
one thing with me guess what you ain't
playing if you're my kid
you ain't playing hockey if you're my
kid i have no clue how to help you play
hockey
god knows dylan could have ended up
being one of the greatest hockey players
of all time dad gets to play
he might be something he ain't never
going to play hockey with daddy he could
have been the first
armenian a syrian hockey player
i'm sorry he has the wrong father for
that game
so the point is if people want to make a
change in any of these areas
it starts off with the top with the most
influential people saying hey why don't
you consider getting
into politics why don't you consider
getting into
business why don't you consider getting
into real estate why don't you consider
going and starting some businesses why
don't you
it's that why don't you consider from
the top and the kid typically will be
inspired
by what that community leader and
parents tell them to do anyways we can
get away from the story
one question let's hope you guys got
finally thought uh a sport that came to
mind why the united states completely
just
shits the bed for some reason soccer
it's soccer yeah why are the men suck
but the women are good i don't
understand that that's just one thing
but there was a speech i was a black
businessman
years ago in front of a group of um
african american kids
and he basically broke down the odds of
becoming an nba player he's basically
all you all want to get to the nba
let me break down some stats for you
there's a half a million
high school basketball players there's
10 000
college basketball players there's 500
nba players so if you're the one of 500
000
um basketball players that play in high
school the chances you make it to the
nba
point zero zero zero zero one whatever
go become something else don't
hinge all your dreams becoming a
basketball player i'm an entrepreneur
become a businessman
i agree the late jimmy valvano talked
about that he said um i was asking these
kids i was talking about graduation
and what do you want to study here at nc
state what do you want to do
and they say i want to i'm going to go
to the nba i'm going to go to the nba so
the three
the three uh recruited freshmen are
sitting his office in the bay
do you know that there's only 17 there
will be 17 players in the draft
that actually are in the nba after three
years
each year in college there'll be 17
players that are still in the nba after
three years
and he says young men it's a really
amazing day
because i just recruited three of them
here at nc state
there you go so the point he's trying to
make right he's trying to make a simple
point
is that hey you know what you do that
low percentage but we're
we've gotten far afield i think
to put a period on it i think we should
be sure that companies are giving
everybody a fair shot
100 but it should and there should be
recourse when they're not
but it's got to be you know based on
skills yeah let's go and hire
on white black latino asian middle
eastern english and
let's go upstream and invest more in
schools and to do the things so that
kids have more capabilities and more
places to go
i agree so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye